well let's talk to one of barbara
windsor's former co-stars the actor lucy
benjamin who played lisa fowler
in eastenders good to see you lucy this
morning
um it is fair to say isn't she that that
barbara windsor
really was a british icon
she she really was in every sense of the
word um
everybody loved her not just people that
worked with her and knew her
but people that didn't know her um i
just think the country will be
will be very very sad today and she was
a she was a brilliant woman and i loved
it
what was it like when you first joined
eastenders to sort of
i can't imagine what it's like to walk
onto that set and then start
working with people like barbara
i think um thinking back to it
i think barbara was the one i was most
star struck by i think went out on my
first
days on set but but what was so lovely
about her was that she she just
immediately
made you feel um welcome and i mean i
was i was lucky she took me under her
wing
and she was led by example
uh she was so professional she always
knew her lines she was never late and
that's what she would
expect from every other actor and
providing you you kind of you did what
you were meant to do
she she'd have time for you and she was
she was always just so lovely to me
um and i feel very grateful that that we
had that connection
what was she actually like as a person
because it's i mean
i would talk about different positions
peggy mitchell compared to the roles she
played in carry on were
couldn't be further apart was she a bit
more
carry on in real life yes she was really
yeah she was always very bubbly um you
never saw barbara down
i i don't i don't remember ever seeing
her dance she loved a good gossip
first thing in the morning when i told
him that she'd always give students news
and she'd call me in her dressing room
and she always had she had all the news
she knew everything about everybody and
she she was just bubbly and charismatic
um and fun to be around
it's i can't imagine actually spending
that time with someone
that iconic because she i mean she
certainly managed to switch it on for
the cameras on eastenders didn't she
peggy mitchell was
fierce oh she was a brilliant actress
um barbara could do comedy like that she
could turn on the tears
and do high drama so i mean i think she
was kind of
underrated as an actress you know she
was really at the top of her game
um and i loved working with her and the
scene you're showing now i remember
watching it uh
you know i was on set at the time as you
can even see i'm you know i'm in the
scene
and she was just on it and she knew what
she was doing and she could just
everyone was just enthralled when they
were watching her i mean there was no
acting required from any of us around
the bar it was just brilliant
what do you make of the fact that that
in in her final years
you know after her diagnosis with
alzheimer's she i mean she
she hasn't gone quietly has she she's
campaigned up until the
the very last moment for for people
with the condition but also people i
know she had a lot of passion for the
for the elderly and the lonely in
society as well
yeah i mean barbara didn't do anything
by half's really um and
and she just she just embraced
everything that she believed in and and
she would she would run with that and
and it's amazing what she's she's done
for the alzheimer's cause and scott
and i know a few of the guys on
eastenders they they ran a marathon
to raise money and awareness for the
charity um
and that's that was just barbara she
would just she would just encompass
everything that she took on and and
and you know put a heart and soul into
everything
i wonder if i mean if you think i'm a
terrible person lucy because i know
people are sad about this and i
absolutely understand that and
especially
if you knew her personally but for
someone like me
all i can do is smile and think but for
the carry-ons for me i just think of
barbara windsor
and i smile just so funny
you know that doesn't make you a bad
person stephen at all it it's
that barbara does bring a smile to
everyone's face and when you were when
you were playing the vts
of her you know before before the
interview i had a big smile on my face
and um it you know of course i'm i'm
so upset about it but she brought joy to
lots of people's lives
um and you know if we can go away just
smiling about her then
she's done her job it's one of those
things isn't it in terms of we often
talk about sort of legacies of people
barbara windsor is someone who i guess
she's never going to be forgotten is she
you know that
an icon in there when we talk of icons
often you think of some of the you know
silver screen american actresses and
things
she's an icon in a very british way
yeah and i think that's what people
people just found her very approachable
i remember being with her
events and opening nights and and and
everyone everyone wanted to meet her
everyone wanted to give her a cuddle
shake her hand
get an autograph and and she was always
so there for people and wanted to do it
wanted to make people happy
she was just such a pro and she knew how
to she knew how to make people happy and
that's why she
she is an icon um she had that
likeability
people did feel that they that they knew
her
um and i suppose that's what encompasses
that word
yeah yeah lovely look lucy really good
to talk to you this morning thank you
very much indeed
thank you